well the President says the problem is
with these Governors like Governor
Abbott and Governor DeSantis Florida who
are shipping off migrants to places far
between take a look at this
Republicans are playing politics with
human beings using them as props what
they're doing is simply wrong it's
Un-American it's Reckless and we have a
process in place to manage migrants of
the Border we're working to make sure
it's safe and orderly and humane
all right now the president specifically
was referring to uh This Plane load that
got off in Martha's Vineyard in
Massachusetts on an island here with a
well to do that was a political stunt it
was egregious saying the same about
Governor Abbott's move to do that with
migrants who found their way to
Washington D.C in Chicago Philadelphia
New York Sanctuary cities all uh and it
got us thinking here this outrage that's
been expressed I I always wonder what
Lieutenant Chris olivarez thinks of the
Texas Department of Public Safety
because Chris uh I I can well remember
it wasn't that long ago and it continues
to this day where the administration and
Ice more specifically has had better
than 900 flights carrying more than 51
000 non-us citizens all over the country
some in the middle of the night and very
few in those affected areas said boo
about anything even though in most cases
they weren't warned at all but now these
couple of instances become the focus
with no reference to those tens of
thousands of citizens transferred under
this in the middle of the night program
what do you make of that
right now you're absolutely right we
know for a fact that over one million
illegal immigrants have been released
into the United States by the federal
government ever since last year and
right now we don't know where those
immigrants are at and of course there
was no acknowledgment there was no
concerns at that point from anyone from
these Mayors or from any local officials
in some of these cities some of these
states where these immigrants were being
bus and flow to by the federal
government but now that Texas and
Florida and Arizona are now taking this
initiative to bust immigrants from their
states to these Sanctuary cities it's
causing concern and again you know and I
mentioned this numerous times on your
show is that they're only experiencing a
small fraction of what Texas experiences
every single day and Governor Abbott
launched this initiative that this bus
strategy initiative to bust these
immigrants to Washington to New York and
now Chicago because the the smaller
border communities were just feeling uh
overrun by immigrants they don't have
the capacity uh border patrol does not
have the processing centers to house the
amount of immigrants that are coming
across daily so to alleviate that we're
busting immigrants from Texas to these
cities and again one thing to make very
clear is that these immigrants are not
being tricked
um they're definitely not being
kidnapped as far you know those
allegations that were made by the
governor out of California these
immigrants have gone through the
processing system they've gone through
the ngos they've been released and now
all we're doing is facilitate hating the
transport to these Sanctuary cities
because these immigrants that's where
they want to go because they know for a
fact that they're going to receive
benefits and they're going to be
welcomed by these Sanctuary cities as
these Mayors and these other local
officials have touted from the very
beginning that they are a city of
immigrants so that's all we're doing
right now and it's causing concern
because now it's forcing the Mayors it's
forcing is the federal government to
actually to actually acknowledge what's
taking place because Governor Abbott and
all these other Governors that are that
are taking part in this bus scene and
also flying these immigrants is actually
setting light on what's taking place on
the border and it's forcing them to
actually acknowledge what's taking place
but again we still have not seen any
strategy or any plan from the federal
government to do something about the
influx of immigrants we're seeing El
Paso is now experiencing influx of
immigrants which they have never done
before so again it's continuing to
escalate and all we're trying to do is
I'm all for fairness or you're going to
criticize something you better be on a
strong position to do the criticizing
right it's just like I would never give
anyone dietary advice it would just be a
bad idea having said that I find it
interesting now that they're criticizing
uh the state of migrants and how they're
put in this horrendous situation and I
don't recall any of the Mayors and those
in these communities uh fretting for
their their condition and how they were
being treated in Texas is when it was
just Texas dealing with this or Arizona
dealing with this I don't remember one
of these guys talking about the better
than 900 flights as I said over the last
two fiscal years right uh to so many
locations Atlanta Baltimore Buffalo
Chicago Dallas Birmingham Alabama
Brownsville Texas Buffalo New York
Columbus Georgia I can go on and on and
on and say about how many of these
flights left in the middle of the night
with no Advance warning handled through
eyes clearly handled through the
administration and no one said boo about
that that's what kind of calls me here
because it's very inconsistent it's a
double standard
it is new it is and the fact that you
know especially you know saying that
it's an American or it's Reckless what's
Un-American and Reckless is encouraging
these migrants to make this long
dangerous Journey where migrants are
dying uh crossing the river dying in the
desert
um being smuggled by human Smugglers
that's not a Humane process uh to have
you know immigration what they should do
and what they need to have a plan is
actually how many more control flow
of immigrants have been coming across as
opposed to having to pay a criminal to
get across the river and we're seeing a
record number of deaths from adults to
children that are trying to get across
into the United States that's not Humane
you know what we're doing is a more
controlled strategy these immigrants are
voluntarily getting on these buses
they're not put in danger they're free
to get off anytime they want along this
transport so it's it's very you know
it's it's a hypocrisy this whole
situation you know from these these
local officials saying that what we're
doing right now is placing these
immigrants in danger well it's part of
the
contrary
I'm sorry exactly I'm sorry my friend
but you're right just be consistent with
this Lieutenant Chris olivar is the
Texas Department of Public Safety hi
winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now